jack irving oil est fidèle à la shdm
aurait lâché au dopage comme on jetait
vous avez gagné peut-être ce matin la
palme du misogyne
bof de cette assemblée est une merde à
[Musique]
limoges elle ne laisse jamais because
the wicker smaller vers le satellite mms
elle laisse ses sols mais d'un seigneur
écoute ado ses routes et ses ressources
thérias jonathan drillet des reds avait
ce talent acquis comme audi potala il
sait qu'elle est voilée c'est que les
vous allez y les préoccupations et las
mujeres bande annonce par les présentes
dans l'hostie d'habanos et nicolas de
conditionner ce côté joaquin benoit
defender à las mujeres européen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a dans notre assemblée souvent des
débats quillan nos différences nos
oppositions nous grandissent et
grandissent notre assemblée
je crains que 8 ce matin soit un débat
qui soit terriblement régressif
j'irai voir pardon vous pouvez répéter
un petit peu plus fort ce que vous venez
de dire monsieur le sénateur vous venez
de dire parce que des fois ne se serait
pas aux jeux vidéo vous venez de dire à
mon propos pendant que je parlais de la
parité c'est qui cette nana je souhaite
que ce soit bien inscrire votre nom s'il
vous plaît monsieur sido voilà bien je
note donc monsieur sido donc je vous
épargnerai le rappel au règlement plus
que je fais je suis actuellement à
intervenir mais je crois que vous avez
gagné peut-être ce matin
la palme du misogyne bof de cette
assemblée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inhumaine cyrine endisqué
hafid leur dicte la politique du
sinistre salle entière et spencer à ses
créateurs on a six voitures n'est in
sostenible 6-1 terminé d'impact social
est sis 1 termine économie celle du code
civil au stade où la situation n'est
yoshi s'élaborer la tchatche com
internet de la sénatrice avait fait
amender les prérogatives du sénateur
immersive idrissa chérif autre de leur
vie à la conception de sa vie au labrit
marie camaret la sénatrice nordique
[Musique]
monsieur ravive se verra des 13-14 je
voulais je vous prévienne toujours mais
monter la mer c'est un goujat c'est un
goujat
et poursuivre et poursuivez en tout cas
c'est pas dans mon bureau c'est ce qui
est scandaleux et odieux personnage y
est une merde ça pourra très bien